Donald Trump touts the wonderful state
of our union last night
well Democrats sat and scowled except
for the Congressional Black Caucus who
wore brightly colored scarves and shawls
presumably to celebrate the National
exuberance of the last year as we have
made America great again it was so it
was really nice of them to do it and
that's why I'm wearing my kuchi sweater
today I want to celebrate too I really
like this sweater it makes me feel like
Biggie Smalls
I'm small E smalls actually that's gonna
be my rap name so we're really fortunate
also to be joined today by Senator Cory
Booker for reaction he's gonna come
right on the show and it's a real honor
to have a US senator here to react so we
will get right to it then the strengths
of intersectionality why conservatism
doesn't matter
and finally guy fawkes dies on this day
in history
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
all right there's a lot to talk about
here some of you might have joined us
last night thank you so much if you came
and hung out with us at the State of the
Union stream party I'm still slightly
hungover from it we spent four hours
smoking stogies and drinking and
watching the State of the Union it's a
lot of fun dennis prager dropped by i
think you can still catch that on yeah
oh well you can't catch it on YouTube
because they shut us down halfway
through CNN fraudulently shut us down
and made a copyright claim on our c-span
stream The Young Turks was using the
same stream and that went up perfectly
fine so I guess you can't find it there
but look for it on Facebook or the Le
wire something like that it was a lot of
fun I'm glad that my headache is
subsiding because we all had a very good
time doing so to get right into it I
want to focus specifically on the
Democrat reaction to some important
moments from last night's State of the
Union and we're joined by Senator Cory
Booker so let's begin Donald Trump said
quote tonight I am asking the Congress
to pass legislation to help ensure
American foreign assistance dollars
always serve American interests and only
go to Friends of America not enemies of
America Cory Booker your thoughts that
hurt and that pain okay since the
election we have created 2.4 million new
jobs this was bad halfway through the
speech including 200,000 new jobs in
manufacturing alone
after years of wage stagnation we are
finally seeing rising wages unemployment
claims have hit a 45 year low
african-american unemployment stands at
the lowest rate ever recorded and
Hispanic American unemployment has also
reached the lowest levels in history
Cory your reaction tens of billions of
Americans tens of millions of Americans
are working yeah tens of millions of
black Americans are working the lowest
unemployment rate in history hundreds of
millions of Americans generally are
working we have really wonderfully low
unemployment right now so surely surely
that must have made you smile I had
tears of rage after introducing parents
whose children were tragically killed by
ms-13 gang members offering compassion
for their heartbreak President Trump
said quote tonight I am calling
the Congress to finally close the deadly
loopholes that have allowed ms-13 and
other criminals to break into our
country we have proposed a new
legislation that will fix our
immigration laws and support our ice and
Border Patrol agents so that this cannot
ever happen again Cory come on you gotta
like that I hurt Trump said quote
preston's reverence for those who have
served our nation reminds us why we
salute our flag why we put our hands on
our hearts for the pledge of allegiance
and why we proudly stand for the
national anthem
I hurt President Trump said
yong-ho traveled thousands of miles on
crutches across China and Southeast Asia
to freedom most of his family followed
his father was caught trying to escape
and was tortured to death today he lives
in Seoul where he rescues other
defectors and broadcasts into North
Korea what the regime fears the most the
truth today he has a new leg butts
yeongho I understand you still keep
those crutches as a reminder of how far
you have come your great sacrifice is an
inspiration to us all I hurt Cory you
were like a broken record Cory thank you
for being here maybe we'll bring you
back later or something not on this guy
kids and they're not happy about
anything at least though and look forget
Cory Booker at least members of the
Congressional Black Caucus they were
exuberant I don't know if you caught it
you should have seen them they were
wearing these beautifully colored shawls
they were very big and bright because
there's mourning in it I'm sorry what's
that hold on one second I'm just kidding
oh oh okay parent Lee I got that wrong
they were wearing the shawls cuz they
hate Trump they were wearing them
because they're angry about something or
whatever they were also wearing black
for some other protest thing or whatever
Democrat rep Al Green said I'm wearing
this to show my solidarity with the
continent of Africa and especially with
those countries that the president
demeaned defamed by indicating they were
s hole or s house countries wearing it
to show that solidarity and to let the
president know that I disapprove of his
statements and his behavior I totally
misread that Democrats were already
wearing black
I lied the me to movement then they
added on top of that the colorful
scarves Democrat Rep Sheila Jackson she
said quote I hope it was a pointed
statement to those that will see this as
a symbol of respect
she said she believes that her Kente
cloth was from Ghana
she believes that it's from Ghana she
doesn't know this is exhibit 755 million
of my central theory of the left that
the left wants the appearance of the
thing but they don't want the essence of
the thing they think that their sixties
radicals they're they're play-acting
protest they think that they're out
there they're in the civil rights
movement because they don't want to
realize that the civil rights movement
worked and Jim Crow is over and
segregation is over and black Americans
have civil rights but they don't want to
admit that cuz that's not as cool it
doesn't look as good on TV it's not as
heroic we're in a decadent and apathetic
age but we want to appear like we're
these wonderful courageous people
actually fighting against something it's
much nicer it's much more luxurious to
just pretend to be fighting against
something than to actually have to go do
it cuz when you actually have to go do
it you get water hoses turned on you and
you get arrested and you get thrown in
jail or worse but now there's did you
just want to look kind of cool right
there wearing the Ghanaian GARP they're
wearing that those she thinks it's gonna
and they don't know I think it's gonna
enter I think it means something I don't
know but they don't want to live in
Ghana
no one's no one's moving to Ghana nobody
wants to be in Ghana and that's where
it's so disingenuous when they hit
Donald Trump over the s whole comments
you know that he allegedly said at a
closed-door meeting he said that a lot
of impoverished countries in Africa and
Haiti are not very nice places to live
he said that mostly because they are
clearly not very nice places to live if
they were really nice places to live we
you would see Americans moving to live
there rather than all of them begging to
come to the United States they are so
disingenuous in in the act itself in the
conversation itself it undercuts their
own argument you can't simultaneously
say those countries are so awful this
country is so wonderful that we owe it
to the rest of the world to let people
from crappy places move to now
nighted states and also those places
aren't crappy and also in simultaneous
imal taneous lee but the left wants to
have the appearance of the thing and
they don't want have to deal with the
with the essence of the thing that which
animates this activism these ideas
this is slacktivism at its finest
they're wearing the black for the me too
they're wearing the Ghanaian thing for
protesting from for some other reason or
because he made improper comments
untoward comments on couth Commons
behind closed doors at a private meeting
what is next what are they are they
gonna wear a little pin for Kony 2012
what about just we Charlie how we're
just going to add ever it will have a
mosaic of faux concern and faux activism
and absolutely empty virtue signaling
and posturing here are two of the
greatest social media supporters of
Donald Trump two of the of only 45
people that he follows on Twitter I keep
trying to become one of the people that
he follows hasn't happened here they are
explaining the ridiculous parade well
that's what these look democratic
lawmakers do they sit down on the
American people that's right here we
have a president that wants to stand for
all Americans yes and you have these
Democratic lawmakers they want to sit
down on us but you know it's not gonna
be tolerated and see I think what they
want to do is take us back to the Jim
Crow day that's right they want to take
us back with their manipulate and
intimidate us and telling us how it's
going to be they want to hand us prompts
it's we it's reminding me of that
president that said we're gonna give you
another I'll keep you quiet but not
enough to make a difference it's time
for a president to stand up and make a
difference that's what President Donald
Trump is doing and it's either the
Democrats can stand up or we can do like
we're trying to grant a path to
citizenship we need to grant them a path
to retirement it's time to retire the
Congressional Black Caucus sat the whole
entire time we'll see these people are
in another they back in the 60s this is
2018 we are in a new era a new America
this man is truly making America great
again why wouldn't you be happy with us
having more money in our pockets see
they want to hand you crumbs we can no
longer vote for a system that's handing
us crumbs anymore we need to vote for a
businessman that wants to make this
place great again and I don't see how
the Democrat
going to get in how they gonna win it in
2018 how they gonna win it at 2020 I
love them so much
I love them so much and they're
absolutely right there they're thinking
on this is so clear because they may
observe just that line alone they're
living in the 60s these people are
living in the 60s they realize that it's
to their political advantage they are
very lightly educated basically
everybody in Congress is very lightly
educated but especially people that do
ridiculous stunts like this the things
have changed there we're in a different
place we're in a different culture and
it's no longer there is no longer an
advantage to pretending to be protesting
for things that haven't existed for 50
years so lest you be tempted to think
ever even in spite of what diamond and
silk just said very articulately very
clearly lest you be tempted to think
that the Congressional Black Caucus
members who frowned and sat in war
coogee colors last night or principled
or politically admirable in any way here
they are here are members of the
self-righteous Congressional Black
Caucus including Barack Obama smiling
taking photos with Louis Farrakhan the
Nation of Islam leader who is famously
said quote white people or potential
humans they haven't evolved yet they
call them terrorists I call them freedom
fighters Judaism is a gutter religion
and Hitler was a very great man language
Fester's quarry that is a great point as
a first good point Cory Booker made all
day long language Fester's now you might
wonder why you've never seen that photo
of Barack Obama with Louis Farrakhan
before that's because the media buried
it we already know that the media do
this we know that there was the
journalist conspiracy of major
mainstream journalists speaking to one
another conspiring on how to hide bad
news about Barack Obama and push a
fluffy pieces to make him more appealing
this was run by Ezra Klein who now has
the audacity in the gall to run voxcom
and say that he is an explanatory
journalist he's nothing but a cheap hack
and a propagandist he's been exposed
spectacularly more than anyone else in
the media he was exposed for being a
hack propagandist and now he comes out
and says I'm the the adult in the room
who's going to explain things to you
also an explainer for Ezra Klein
all journalism is supposed to be
explanatory that's what language does
but that's neither here nor there
Hillary Clinton tried to make this Louis
Farrakhan thing an issue during the 2008
race she kept trying to get Barack Obama
to reject Farrakhan support so you have
to reject his support Obama played coy
the whole time he said he denounced it
but he wouldn't reject it and he's
trying to find some distinction without
a difference had this photo come out
Hillary Clinton could be President had
that photo come out of Barack Obama and
other CBC members smiling with a
hatemonger like Louis Farrakhan very
likely he wouldn't be President and she
would be President but it's still
happening they're still covering up for
these guys it this photo that one of the
reason you haven't seen it now is it was
unearthed by some kind of lefty
journalists to the major networks are
not covering it Fox is the only one
that's covering it the rest will not
touch this thing you're trying to down
flow it they'll allude to it but they
won't cover it in depth because it just
doesn't it doesn't fit the narrative and
if it doesn't fit the narrative they're
not gonna run it not to put too fine a
point on this Congressional Black Caucus
members will not smile at low black
unemployment but they will smile with a
man who says that white people aren't
yet humans and that Hitler was a very
great man that's the Congressional Black
Caucus imagine for a moment if there
were a congressional white caucus it
sounds absurd it would be absurd in fact
imagine that any white member of
Congress met with a white racist a white
purveyor of racial division like David
Duke or Richard Spencer or whomever
imagine the endless reporting imagine
the endless coverage they would be not
only run out of Congress they would be
run out of the country tarred and
feathered on a rail do you remember Mean
Girl Jake Tapper yeah grilling Donald
Trump during the campaign CNN employs
that mean girl Jake Tapper and he was
grilling Trump do you do you disavow
David Duke meanwhile Donald Trump said
15 years earlier he said David dukes an
idiot I don't want to be associated with
him at all I don't like him he's
terrible there's no place for him at all
but then for some reason Jake Tapper
just decided to bring this up again
because it was a good cudgel to hit
Donald Trump with so do you disavow
David Duke and Trump said what do you
mean David do what are you getting David
Duke from why are you asking me these
stupid questions these questions that
are basically akin to do you still beat
your wife do you either either way you
answer that your your
implicating yourself your your defending
against a harsh accusation you're
playing into it with any response do you
disavow David to exam dare you associate
me with David Dirk Obama didn't get that
treatment he didn't get that treatment
with Farrakhan I'm Donald Trump you
don't see photos of Donald Trump smiling
with David Duke and shaking hands thumbs
up but you do see that with Louis
Farrakhan and Barack Obama he met him he
posed for pictures smiled at him so the
Congressional Black Caucus will sit and
scowl for record-low black unemployment
but they will smile for a racist
anti-american Haim longer that's because
they're charlatans they don't represent
their constituents any of the
constituents they claim to represent
pure charlatans they should not be
treated as representative of anybody
their district constituents black
Americans none of them every Democrat
who sat last night for the American flag
the national anthem and low unemployment
is a farce and a fraud and should not be
afforded any respect as a political
leader not for one a single second that
said keep it up guys keep it up bring it
on this was excellent for Republicans
Trump clearly did it on purpose
he backs them into corners so when he
said we need to stand for our flag and
our anthem what he was really saying is
you I'm going to force you Democrats
into a bad photo op because they've
spent a year now two years now saying
that NFL players should not stand for
the flag so anything they do if they
stand up they're weak because they've
flip-flopped on their position on the
NFL if they sit they look profoundly on
American which they are in which they
did look like when Donald Trump walked
in one one thing to notice some we were
joking about it on the stream he was
himself applauding so he walks in and
he's applauding he's on the stage he's
applauding and this is really nice
people were trying to say that this is
narcissistic he's applauding himself
that's not what he's doing it's actually
exactly the opposite there are a few
things here there's a guy lessness about
this there's an innocence about this he
clearly is new at being the president
and at being a politician at all and you
can see that he's a little rough around
the edges he doesn't quite know he
appears quite humbled by it but it's
also humbling if he walks in he's
walking in for the State of the Union
and he's applauding now what one read is
that he's applauding himself but it
didn't look like it he's looking around
he actually stepped away from the podium
before he began speaking he was standing
to the side and looking around and
clapping at everybody
this isn't like when true narcissists
like Bill Clinton or Barack Obama walk
in they feel like they're King Caesar
marching into Rome Donald Trump isn't
there - for the State of the Union to be
the Trump accolades parade it Adam
surprisingly it wasn't that he was there
to laud the State of the Union he was
applauding the State of the Union
there's a lovely humility in that which
you can only get from a guy who plasters
his name on every building in the world
do you know there's a lovely irony and
something very American about the guests
were great - a Donald Trump invited
David Dahlberg firefighter who saved 62
children and staff from a summer camp in
the California wildfires he invited
Ashlee Leppert a Coast Guard technician
who rescued dozens from the Hurricanes
John Bridgers founder of the Cajun Navy
to help hurricane Harvey officer Ryan
who lets a cop who was shot twice on the
job who adopted a child from parents
addicted to opioids corporal Matthew
Bradford who lost his sight and both
legs on a deployment in Iraq first blind
w amputee - reenlist in the marine corps
ever a staff sergeant Justin Peck he
saved a fellow American service member
from an AED in Syria Preston sharp he's
a young boy who organized the placement
of American flags and red carnations on
more than 40,000 soldiers graves Steve
stobe and Sandy Keplinger
small business owners how long has it
been since we saw small business owners
lauded in particular at one of these
speeches corey adams a welder a worker
at stokes company for parents whose
daughters were killed tragically by the
gang ms-13 Celestino martinez an ISO
officer who hunts down those gangs
compare this to Barack Obama's in 2016
Obama didn't invite anybody the invites
were a tradition were started by Ronald
Reagan but by 2016 Obama wasn't running
anymore he'd had enough of that he
invited lots of people almost every year
2016 nobody in 2015 the last year he did
it he invited Mark Kelly Mark Kelly as
you might recall he's the husband of
Gabby Giffords so the idea was that
Barack Obama invited him because he was
going to go
on a mission into space to prepare the
way for America to send a manned mission
to Mars that was ostensibly the reason
that's not really the reason Mark Kelly
is a major gun control advocate and
Barack Obama was trying to grab guns for
his entire presidency Barack Obama began
the presidency by moaning all of those
rubes in the country who cling bitterly
to their guns and to their religion that
was the purpose it was a political dig
in an anti-american one at that Alan
Gross who Barack Obama took credit for
releasing from a Cuban prison as a way
to sell his total caving to the demands
of the Castro regime he was the other
guy that Barack Obama invited that year
you know a Trump gives invites and that
people to whom from gives invites you
know it highlights important aspects of
our country important sides of our
country
workers servicemen sheriff
philanthropists patriotic kids victims
of crime that we have to address the the
Democrats held six state separate State
of the Union responses last night nobody
watched any of them I even we didn't we
were supposed to be streaming one we
watched twenty seconds of that Kennedy
kid drooling on himself we said we can't
watch this anymore in front of a broken
car presumably to call attention to the
fact that Democrats destroyed Detroit so
we turn that off and we just kept
drinking and hanging out here is one
short clip from the celebrity organized
people's
State of the Union
[Music]
[Music]
yesterday today then we get a gift by
these various struggles and the one
silver lining in Trump is that we have
created the mother of all movements we
have I think my face is gonna be in a
permanent state of cringe so that last
guy at the end was Mark Ruffalo he's
that professional protester who
occasionally does superhero movies or
something and previously you heard that
awful singing the lyrics were terrible
they were just rhyming day with day and
they didn't have a point and the points
they made didn't make any sense and it
sounded terrible these are supposed to
be the entertainers these are supposed
to be people to entertain us and they
don't entertain us they're not even when
they try to they aren't good they
they're not there isn't any proficiency
or skill or talent in any of this they
were wearing a shirt that said we are
all dreamers or something like that
these people are doing politics now
because they aren't good at art they
aren't that great at art if they spent a
quarter of the time that they spend
ranting ignorant Lee about politics they
spend a quarter of that on their craft
they would be much better in that
harmonica thing wouldn't have popped out
my eardrum okay I've got my most
important takeaways from the State of
the Union we've got much more to talk
about why intersectionality really does
work this is terrifying but it is we
have to admit it and why conservatism
per se it doesn't matter but first
before we do any of them we got to talk
about these are
dangerous times folks and we have got to
talk about ring so I've talked about
ring a lot you've heard me talk about
their home security camera I love it
its innovative it's totally the 21st
century way so they've been sending us
actual footage of ring busting crooks in
the act this is one that I wanted to
share with you on this show so I'll set
it up a woman runs up to a porch to
steal a package from the doorstep and
then look at what happens hey put that
down I just stopped someone from was she
wearing a pink hat I don't it looked
like she was wearing a pink hat so she
runs up she's gonna steal this package
and then the guy is on his ring app and
he was talking to her he said put my
package down what are you doing and then
she just she doesn't even acknowledge
just puts it down runs away into the car
she got completely cuts really
unbelievable and and ring video doorbell
because we've heard these stories there
was a study in a downtown LA somewhere
at some neighborhood around LA where
ring gave out a bunch of its product to
a high crime area and home burglaries
went down by 55% in six months so you
hear these statistics but here you
actually it's Amberson and it's very
entertaining so I wanted to show it it's
a really effective way to stop package
theft because thieves just cannot hide
with a ring even if they try to steal
your ring the video is up in the cloud
so you can get him anyway the look on
her face says it all she was caught
red-handed she drops the package runs
away the ring video doorbell lets you
see and speak to intruders on your
smartphone from anywhere even share
video clips to your neighbors using the
ring app so if this little crook and the
pink cat runs up and tries to steal your
package you can say get out of here and
then you can share that video to your
neighbors and say hey watch your
packages we got a crook in the
neighborhood a rings flood light camera
is really good to spotlight camera is
really good they let you bring a ring of
security around your entire property
you'll know the floodlight cameras
that's when the derelicts you in my
audience will run under someone's
property to break in or something and
then a light hits you and then you run
away that that's what it does exhibit
also has a camera and uploads all of
that to the clouds you can see it from
any
we're from a beach in Bali or your
office or whatever stop crime before it
happens
help make your neighborhood safer with
ring people used to do neighborhood
watches that was the old-timey way to do
things with mixed results this is the
21st century get with the 21st century
you know you're not gonna chase down the
robbers and a horse and buggy either
this is the way to do it now it's much
less expensive it's much easier you can
do it from anywhere you have to get it
you can save up to $150 on a ring of
security kit at ring.com / Knowles K
nowl
es just like the last name of jay-z's
wife k nowl es that's ring comm /
Knowles
$150 off when you go to ring comm /
Knowles Marshall what is it ring.com /
Knowles okay the big takeaways from last
night by all tangible measures the state
of our union is strong by all the
tangible measures militarily as a matter
of the economy as a matter of the the
bureaucracy shrinking as a matter of the
judges who have been appointed more a
judges appointed in this first year than
ever in history and they're all good
originalist hsihu are actually going to
interpret laws in the Constitution as
they were written all wonderful stuff
there was a lot of North Korea talk
North Korea victim was invited to the
event one wonders how much time a little
Rocket Man has it to live on earth I
really looked like the build-up to some
action that should have probably been
taken 25 years ago so good on him on the
intangibles on the culture we haven't
been this divided in at least half a
century maybe longer they're clearly no
they wouldn't stand up for America they
wouldn't stand up for the flag this is
weird people say Donald Trump is so
weird and so strange he's president
Trump is like perfectly normal compared
to these people who are sitting for
their own country it's so disgusting and
outrageous all of that does show the
strength of intersectionality we've
heard this term bandied about
intersectionality is defined as the
interconnected nature of social
categorizations
such as race class gender as they apply
to a given individual or group regarded
as creating overlapping and
interdependent systems discrimination or
disadvantage the word was invented in
1980
by a feminist named Kimberly Crenshaw
it's such a fake term by the way that I
was writing this out my word processor
put a little squiggly underneath it
that's how new this is I don't might
word isn't that old you know but this is
the strength of intersectionality so you
saw the illegal aliens were a big
political issue last night nobody would
care about illegal aliens if not for
intersectionality I'm old enough to have
worked on political campaigns when it
was a given when it was on both sides of
the aisle that playing to illegal aliens
doesn't work for anybody because we
don't want people breaking our laws and
the illegal aliens theoretically can't
vote obviously Democrats are doing their
best to make sure that they can
especially in my home state of
California but obviously it makes
perfect sense that no one would care
about illegal aliens as a political
matter because we're the voters we by
definition if only people who are not
illegal aliens can vote you wouldn't
play to that except for
intersectionality what intersectionality
does is create this hostile toxic
divisive a world in which you are
convinced you are brainwashed into
imagining oppression everywhere
everywhere among every person except for
whatever contrivance it's at the top
probably in this in this version of the
culture is straight white men who think
that they're men but if you're a man who
thinks he's a woman that's okay you get
to go then you're one of the good people
and the only bad people are the straight
white men who think they're men right up
at the top and in that way all of the
division that you would have among
different groups say for instance
taxpayers and illegal aliens or American
citizens and illegal aliens who are
killing them and lowering their wages
and increase in crime and taking a lot
of welfare and lowering standards and
schools because a lot of them don't
speak any English and are illiterate
those groups might have had some
friction with one another except for
intersectionality teaching them everyone
has to get along except for the man
sitting at the top and it has clearly
worked the term was only going to 1989
just a few decades later it has
fundamentally transformed the Democrat
Party and fundamentally transformed
American national politics this is
really scary and we need to figure out a
way to
stop it we need to figure out a way
certainly we on the right should never
play into these intersectional games and
tropes and euphemisms but we really have
to stop it it is poison and it will only
last so long you can't erode the heart
of the American culture forever
eventually it will just collapse around
itself
one last happier takeaway is that Donald
Trump is a good politician so here's the
line of the night my duty and the sacred
duty of every elected official in this
chamber is to defend Americans to
protect their safety their families
their communities and their right to the
American dream because Americans are
dreamers too Americans are dreamers too
excellent spline of the speech it was
the one that everybody remembered I
think Stephen Miller wrote this speech
Stephen Miller is wonderful with
language he went out a little long this
speech could have been a third shorter
it was just too long but it was
excellent through and through if he had
just condensed it a little bit more it
would have been great his use of
language is superb
Trump delivered it very well he's
clearly a good politician and hit the
people who work for him or good
politicians because almost every line of
this speech was crafted to put Democrats
in impossible corners where they would
have to face their own anti-americanism
and look bad for the cameras and I'll I
to have one final take away this one is
an important one for conservatives I
started to mention this last night
during the livestream but we got cut off
by the speech so here it is
there is no conservatism without people
I see this a lot on Twitter people talk
about this and what about okay well this
is good the conservative governance has
been good in the State of the Union is
great and the speech the State of the
Union is great and the taxes are going
to enter data but what about
conservatism what about the ISM is the
ISM okay there it there isn't a
conservatism absent people there isn't a
conservatism without time and space and
people this is a classic error that the
rationalists fall into sometimes talking
about rationalism and politics this is
the classic error conservatism that
first of all that that implies that
conservatism is an ideology and that's a
very modern concept that Bill Buckley
didn't think it was an ideology Russell
Kirk didn't think it was an ideology
Edmund Burke certainly didn't think it
was an ideology all of founders of what
we would consider conservative thought
modern conservative thought didn't think
this ideology is a formalized abridged a
rational sub thought of of the tradition
conservatism robots all of that we
but the we resist the age of ideologies
period so I wouldn't say that I'd say
the conservative thought conservative
coalition is a pulls from a lot of
different philosophies and views of the
world and importantly institutions and
traditions and the tradition it pulls
from all of that and all value isn't
fleshed all value comes through men
doing things that's oh that's the only
way that value has any meaning in this
world is in time and space and through
men doing things and right now we have a
government we have a Speaker of the
House named Paul Ryan we have a
vice-president named Mike Pence we have
a president United States named Donald
Trump we have cabinet officials we have
the Congress we have the Senate we have
Supreme Court justices and these are men
who are doing things they are the ones
who are doing and a lot of people are
attacking them for that because they are
the vessel of conservative thought and a
conservative agenda if it were different
people the left would be doing precisely
the same thing and it is a huge mistake
for conservatives to attack them and to
pull away from them and not to support
them because they are doing our agenda
if they stop doing that if they betray
what we would like to do and betray our
agenda by all means attack them and find
a new vessel for those thoughts and
those ideas and those goals but while
they're doing it support them and do it
that this is it it's very tempting to
say oh you know I like conservative
things I like what Trump's doing but
he's icky and I'm much better than he is
but no he's the one doing it he is the
one affecting that agenda along with
Congress along with the Senate along
with that all of the judges that he's
appointing you should support that it's
that is conservative that is what the
conservative thought leads one to do and
you shouldn't be beguiled by rationalist
and ideological and essentially leftist
ideas on how values relate to the real
world this is the real world we're doing
great things we're making America great
again so be happy about it and we're
exuberant colors just like the
Congressional Black Caucus because we
should celebrate okay let's get to this
day in history but first I'm sorry this
a good this day in history this is a
really good people don't know anything
about this did this day in
this day in history but I'm sorry if
you're watching on Facebook and YouTube
I'll have to say goodbye to you now I
assume you're not watching on YouTube
because CNN probably took this feed down
to and YouTube probably obliged but if
you're watching on Facebook you've got
to go over to daily wire.com daily
wire.com is where you get me you get the
Andrew Clavin sure you get the Ben
Shapiro sure you get the conversation
with Alicia and I am going to be on the
next episode so you can ask only members
can ask questions but everybody can
watch many are called few are chosen
you also can send in questions to the
mailbag you also get no ads on the
website you get a lot of stuff blah blah
blah this guy's this is what you need
the State of the Union is strong and the
leftist tears are welling up I actually
I might need a second one just from Cory
Booker's appearance on our show today I
might need to catch all of those Cory is
just one of these guys he is just one of
these Democrats who are pouring out salt
he left us tears so make sure you go
over there at $10 a month $100 a year
and you get the only proven vessel to
capture all of the radioactive left is
tears daily wire calm we'll be right
back
[Music]
okay are we ready let's get to this day
in history this day in history this is a
fitting this day in history as they
frequently are all nature is but art
unknown to thee on this day in history
in 1606 Guy Fawkes the chief conspirator
in the plot to blow up the British
Parliament building jumped to his death
on the way up to be executed you all
know the Guy Fawkes mask it's worn by
pseudo rebellious idiots who occupy wall
street and wear gynecological headwear
while they shriek profanities in protest
of nothing in particular you've seen
these things it's come to serve as a
universal symbol of resistance of
protest but ask any of the people
wearing the masks and I would bet you my
Shapiro election check that they have no
idea who Guy Fawkes is or what he stood
for so I rather like this story as the
resident papist at the Daily wire I look
forward to harshing all the lefties
Melos the night before the general
parliamentary session in 1605 on
November 4th justice of the peace Sir
Thomas Niven discovered Guy Fawkes in
the cellar of the parliament building
with 4,000 pounds of gunpowder Fox
belonged to a group of disillusioned
English Catholics organized by Robert
Catesby who sought to blow up
figuratively and literally
England's Protestant government all the
way up to King James the first who was
set to attend Parliament that day on
November 5th
now James notoriously persecuted both
aspects of my ancestry English Puritans
and Catholics there are a few subjects
on which Catholics and Mayflower
passengers agree James the first is one
of them in the ensuing months after
Fox's capture English authorities
rounded up and killed all of the
conspirators in the Gunpowder Plot
in addition to arresting torturing and
killing dozens of English Catholics who
had absolutely nothing to do with it Guy
Fawkes was sentenced to be hanged drawn
and quartered by January 31st but as he
climbed the ladder rather than give the
Anglicans that pleasure he jumped from
the ladder and broke his own neck a Guy
Fawkes Day is celebrated throughout
Great Britain on the 5th of November
with fireworks bonfires the burning in
effigy of Guy Fawkes
celebrating the day that Protestant
England survived one wonders how
differently English history and world
history would have progressed had the
plot prevailed English Henry the eighth
rather famously broke Britain away from
her ancestral Catholic faith
despite in 1521 having written a book so
critical of Martin Luther that Pope Leo
the tenth gave him the title defender of
the faith an ironic title because in
1535 frustrated that the Pope kept
stymieing Henry's desires to divorce and
murder his wives and Rhee declared
himself supreme head of the Church of
England for which he was excommunicated
by Pope Paul the 3rd in 1570 pope saint
pius v excommunicated Henry's younger
daughter Elizabeth the first and
declared her officially deposed for her
persecution of Catholics in England and
we are not just talking about your
everyday run-of-the-mill persecution of
Catholics what we're seeing throughout
the world for so long we're talking
about behead your own sister Mary Queen
of Scots for being Catholic kind of
persecution of Catholics is this sort of
persecution that makes many literary
scholars think Shakespeare was a secret
Catholic anyway
after Elizabeth's death in 1603 James
the sixth of Scotland succeeded her and
became James the first of England anyway
they changed their names a lot or their
reigning names so he became James the
first James was a Protestant but unlike
Elizabeth he had never been a Catholic
there was no time at which he was a
Catholic James is the first cradle
Protestant monarch of England and it's
easy for us now especially watching the
crown or whatever movies are coming out
it's easy for us to think of England as
a Protestant country but you shouldn't
forget Catholicism reigned in England
for well over a thousand years there
have been for much longer than any
Protestant reign multiples as long there
had been Celtic Christianity largely in
accordance with Rome from the 1st
century AD and st. Augustine of
Canterbury brought the first
authoritative papal mission establishing
a direct link between the Kingdom of
Kent and the sea of Rome in 597 had the
Gunpowder Plot worked dislodge from
England the merely two generations old
Protestantism affected by two murderers
one who killed his wives and the other
who killed her sister would England have
river
to her ancestral Catholic faith would
the King James version of the Bible
considered by many the greatest work of
the English language would that exist
all good questions made more urgent by
the deplorable state of the Church of
England today a husk of ecclesiology and
Great Britain generally but the more
personal question for all of us is what
precisely is meant by the Guy Fawkes
masks in our cultural and political
battles today who are the real rebels
and who has God on their side
good questions on that note I will tell
you that's the end of our show we have a
fun one tomorrow make sure you get all
of your mailbag questions in and until
then I'm Michael Moss this is the
Michael Nolt show I will see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer Mathis Glover
our technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex zingaro audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2018